so this is a famous psychological
demonstration but many of you might not
have seen it you read that as ABC you
read you read verses 12 13 14 but the B
and the 13 are physically identical
so this tells us something quite
important about the way that that
associative machinery and system one
work on new stimuli
everything is made coherent so in the
context of letters that ambiguous
stimulus is going to be read as a letter
in the context of numbers it is going to
be read as a number what is quite
important there are two aspects here one
is the coherence and the other is that
you're not aware of the ambiguity the
ambiguity is suppressed
that is you just get one interpretation
in this case it's a coherent
interpretation and that is the way that
the system works it generates
associatively coherent representations
or reactions to uh situation the way I I
discuss it in the Black Swan is I talk
about the domain dependence about the
Reebok Club in New York
where people go get in their gym clothes
and then take the the elevator
to the to the stairmasters and then get
on stairmasters and log their 112 floors
stories and then stuff and then take a
log of it okay so you have domain
dependence people not recognizing
something in the texture of real life
associative memory or system one uh is
also the repository of Our World
Knowledge
so when an event occurs our reaction to
it is informed by a lot of things that
we know and I'll give you my favorite
example of this
this is people are listening to
sentences while they're events in their
brain are recorded and somebody an upper
class
male British voice says I have a large
tattoo I have large tattoos all down my
back
and approximately three tenths of a
second later the brain responds with a
characteristic signature surprise
this is astonishing if you stop to think
about it I mean there was that voice you
have to classify it as an upper class
British voice now upper class British
men don't have tattoos down their back
something is odd and you get a surprise
reaction you get a mobilization of
system two because system two is the one
that pays attention surprise calls
attention to uh to the event
you know a male voice saying I believe
I'm pregnant let's go same thing uh so
this system
holds a World Knowledge and uses Our
World Knowledge to classify situations
as normal or abnormal and it does this
at top speed
and it updates very quickly
uh well I'll tell you a story about
updating uh
it updates what what it considers normal
now this is an anecdote you're free not
to believe me I believe it because it's
a personal experience uh we were some
years ago on vacation in in Australia
and a resort all of 40
40 level Villas and
and in the evening we go to have dinner
first evening and we meet a psychologist
from Stanford
oh you know surprise coincidence and
we're very delighted to meet each other
now two weeks later we're in the theater
in London
um
the
it goes dark
and we watch
and then the lights come back on and
next to me same guy
now
the important point is that I was less
surprised the second time on the first
because oh John you know he's the guy I
meet everywhere I mean the
it takes very little time to create what
we call a norm
so one event the second event links back
to the first
if I had met anybody else that is what
what's interesting if I had met anybody
else I would have been more surprised
that's and that's odd if you think about
it statistically it is crazy but in fact
it was very clear that and I wouldn't
say that I consciously expect to see
drone wherever I go but but I you know
if I'm going to meet someone I
I'd be prepared to meet John
I struggled for a lot of my life to have
certain material and social successes
and when I achieve those material and
social successes or at least beyond the
point where they didn't matter as much
to me anymore I realized that my peer
group and a lot of the people who are
around me and the people who had
achieved the similar successes and were
on their way to achieving more and more
successes just didn't seem all that
happy and uh and in my case there was
definitely hedonic adaptation I'd very
quickly get used to anything so
led me to the conclusion which seems
trite that happiness is internal and so
then that set me on a path of starting
to work more on my internal self and
realizing that all real success is
internal and has very little to do with
external circumstances
now I've mentioned something about
causal thinking and I want to give you
some sense of how that works
so it's a question which is more
probable
that a mother has blue eyes if her
daughter has blue eyes or that the
daughter has blue eyes if her mother has
blue eyes
now again as in the Baton ball there is
an intuitive response
and the intuitive response is that it's
more probable that the daughter has blue
eyes if her mother has blue eyes than
the other way around
if you stop to do the math on the
assumption that the incidence of blue
eyes are the same in the two generations
the probabilities are strictly equal
but even before you do the math
your reasoning flows along causal lines
your thinking flows along calls the line
this happens intuitively it's not and
one of these feels okay it feels more
coherent and and the coherence that we
experience can be turned into a judgment
of probability
that is the confidence that we
experience is the Judgment of problem
now let me leave you with a story from
Nasim taleb's Black Swan which
illustrates this tendency of thinking in
Council lines
one day in December 2003 when Saddam
Hussein was captured Bloomberg News
flashed the following headline at 1301.
U.S treasuries rice Hussein capture may
not curb terrorism Whenever there is a
market move the news media feel
obligated to give the reason half an
hour later they had to issue a new
headline as these U.S treasury bonds
fell in price Bloomberg News had a new
reason for the fall saddam's captor the
same Saddam at 1331 they issued the next
bulletin U.S treasure is full Hussain
capture boosts Allure of risky assets so
it was the same capture explaining one
event and its exact opposite clearly
this can't be these two facts cannot be
linked it happens all the time a course
is proposed to make you swallow the news
and make matters more concrete any
conceivable cause can do end of quote
Daniel kaneman also talked about this in
his book Thinking Fast and Slow he
growed Hussein's capture was the major
event of the day and because of the way
the automatic search for causes shapes
or thinking that event was destined to
be the explanation of whatever happened
in the market on that day all headlines
do is satisfy or need for coherence
and finally on the context dependence of
our minds Nasim to let growth in his
book anti-fragile this lack of
translation is a mental handicap that
comes with being a human and we will
only start to attain wisdom or
rationality when we make an effort to
overcome and break through it and if you
want to go over the main takeaways of
both of these Classics I recommend you
to check out short form which is my
favorite website for books story guides
and takeaways and you can use my
affiliate link shortform.com speaking
nuggets to get a 5 day free trial and a
20 discount on the annual subscription
you can also find the link in the
description below
[Music]
thank you